Naturally, once you've
initialized a dictionary,
you're going to want to add items to it.
To add a key value pair to a dictionary,
set the value for
the key using subscript syntax.
Here we're adding a couple entries
to our animal groups dictionary.
A group of crows is called a murder.
I always thought that was a strange one.
And a group of monkeys
is called a troop.
And if we use the count method,
which has the same syntax as the array
structs count method, we can see where,
as before we had three entries in
our dictionary, now we have five.
Removing a value from a dictionary
looks very similar to adding a value,
but in this case, the value for
the key is assigned to nil.
And after we assign the value for
crows to nil,
we can see that the crows murder pair
has been removed from the dictionary.
What if we want to change
the value associated with a key?
For this, we have a couple options.
We can keep using the same versatile
subscript syntax like this.
Here, let's change the monkeys value
to be barrel instead of troop.
Or we can use the method
updateValue forKey.
This method is interesting because
it returns an optional value.
This is good because if you try to
update a value that's not in your
dictionary, your program won't crash.
The updateValue method will just
return nil and go ahead and
add the new key value
pair to the dictionary.
And here you can see we've added a crash
of rhinoceroses to our dictionary.
If the dictionary does contain
the value you try to update,
the updateValue forKey method
returns the former value,
the old value, like we saw here
when the method returned flock.
If you want to retrieve the value for
a particular key, you can use,
you guessed it, subscript syntax,
in other words,
the dictionary name followed
by the key in square brackets.
One has to be a little bit careful when
retrieving values from dictionaries
because retrieving a value for
a given key from a dictionary
returns an optional.
Why would a dictionary
return an optional?
I'm just going to pause for a few
seconds and let you think about it.
It returns an optional because there's
always a chance that the key value pair
you're looking for
isn't in the dictionary.
There are many cases in which
a program might ask for
a value from a dictionary, not knowing
whether it will be there or not.
So it returns an optional, and naturally
that optional needs to be unwrapped.
We unwrap a value returned from
a dictionary using if let,
just like we'd unwrap
any other optional.
In this example, we want to retrieve
the value for a group of whale and
use that value in this print statement.
So we unwrap it like so, and here you
can see the optional has a value, pod.
So what happens if the key isn't found?
No problem, we're covered,
like in this example.
Sasquatches are not in our dictionary.
The optional has a nil value.
But that's okay because we've specified
exactly what we want the program to do
in case of a nil value.